dude this is what it feels like to be a  human this is beautiful I'm so grateful  for everything sippington City shall we  I'm peculiar and I'm okay with it I'm  peculiar and I'm okay with this at the  end of the day necessarily because  you're a good girl and you know it oh  [ __ ] you act different around me what  was that it's a Drake song I want my  videos to let people know they could  truly do whatever they want to do and  people hit me up all the time fulcrum  your videos motivate me to go to the gym  I don't even go to the goddamn gym I'm  about to smoke some Crystal family  foreign  I want to tell you five things bro like  I kind of been holding it in oh man yeah  bro like you promise you won't judge me  bro go yeah because before I got here  man  at the end of the day bro I'm just gonna  let it out bro  [Music]